back to something I briefly mentioned
earlier which is selective attention
selective filtering and value tagging
and that is that we're so bombarded with
information in the modern day that what
you would read in a newspaper in one day
today is the amount of information that
somebody would have received in their
lifetime 100 years ago and even a
hundred years ago people were overly
bombarded with information so it's gone
exponential so for similar reasons to
how we're not aware of our clothes on
our body all day the brain naturally
filters out things that aren't vital to
our survival and if we are not mindful
then that's being chosen subconsciously
without us having any you know impact on
that but if we do something like create
a vision board or visualize something
that we want then we're training the
brain more to be aware of the things
that we really want so then when it does
the selective filtering it doesn't
filter out that person that could
introduce you to somebody about your
business or that person that could
introduce you to somebody for a day
eight you know because you might think
well that's not really important for me
today I need to put food on the table I
need to get this document done
but those sort of more long-term
important things the brain will just not
filter them out and then you're more
likely to pay attention and basically
that means noticing and then grasping
opportunities that can move you closer
to your goal and the value tagging is a
system that literally tags in order of
importance of things that you want in
life but it's partly logical and partly
emotional so logical will be the very
basic fundamental these are the things I
need to survive and then the emotional
will be more like your wishes and your
desires like the innermost things the
longer term things and often logical
trumps emotional so you have to move
that balance and keep reminding yourself
these are the things that I really want
and then your brain adapts to you rather
than you just being kind of not the kind
of driver of the journey hey friends
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this clip then click here for
the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye